welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and looking back on Avengers
endgame and looking ahead to the Falcon
Man Winter Soldier one mystery that
haunts me is what did Bucky know and
when did he know it you don't know what
I'm talking about
lucky you you have a normal brain that
is not obsessed with minor details from
a filament we should probably all just
move on from but I am referring to the
moment at the end of Avengers endgame
when Captain America was preparing to
time travel back in time to return each
of the Infinity stones the Bucky gives
him this little knowing farewell don't
do anything stupid till I get back
how can i you're taking all the stupid
with you
gonna miss you buddy it's gonna be okay
buck now on first glance this is just a
sweet goodbye between two old pals the
Captain America theme music underscores
the moment and Bucky is making a call
back all the way back to the first
Captain America film don't do anything
stupid until I get back how can I taking
all the stupid with you what is it about
these soldiers and their callbacks on
your left on your left what on second
glance or if your May 30th glance it's
clear that Bucky knew that cap was not
coming back from this trip and games
directors and screenwriters confirmed it
with Stephen McFeely saying it's clear
from Sebastian's performance here that
he's been clued in to steve's decision
and joe russo saying he knows now we
don't know the extent to which what
steve told him but clearly he told him
something it is this mystery
conversation that we need to investigate
not just because what was said but which
Steve said it to Bucky yes I propose
that James Buchanan Barnes was actually
more implicated with Steve Rogers secret
off-screen time-travel mission than it
seems
in that the Winter Soldier a former
Hydra Sasson whose ledger drips with all
kinds of sins we'll never know about is
covering up yet another now the simplest
explanation for what Bucky knew was that
he and cap simply just had a
conversation as cap was suiting up and
packing up that suitcase with the minute
he stones like Steve could have said
buck he don't tell the others but after
I drop off these stones awkwardly forced
Jane Foster to read the reality stone
sludge and give red skull some stink eye
as they throw the soul stone back over
that cliff I'm gonna stay in the 1940s
with Peggy Carter and live out my life
in a whole new timeline with her can I
come with you
no it's harder to get dinner
reservations for three than for two
all right get it yeah totally plausible
conversation but the stranger element of
the scene is Bucky's reaction upon
seeing old cat sitting on the bench Sam
go ahead in addition to Bucky knowing
that cap intended to stay in the past
he also seems to know that cap would
return as an old man and would want to
hand off his shield to Sam why would he
say go ahead in this moment if it were
my best friend showing up as an old man
on a bench
I'd run over there and be like whoa dude
best magic trick ever
you look like Clint Eastwood it'd just
be like a slap in the jowls
the cap would have known in that
previous conversation that he would have
lived his whole life and then decades
later found a way to come back to this
timeline cap wouldn't have known enough
to be able to tell Bucky to be chill
when he as an old man would show up out
of the blue to hand off the shield to
say I'm not him
however Bucky's chilled demeanor when he
does tell Sam to go ahead suggests that
he must have been emotionally prepared
for this moment oh well there are two
explanations for this both of which are
kind of creepy when you think about them
too hard
explanation one is that we are applying
the wrong theory of time-travel to the
end of this film previously we have
discussed how the directors and the
screenwriters are split on what exactly
happened with cap in the final minutes
of the movie the directors claim that
cap going back to the 1940s created a
split new history an alternate timeline
that we never see what I'm calling the
new timeline theory which is consistent
with endgames theory of time-travel
creating new branch timelines when
significant things happen in the past
the screenwriters in contrast claim that
no new branch timeline was formed that
cap simply lived on within our history
the same timeline theory in that cap
aged into an old man in the background
of the MCU events that we had been
watching this whole time and he just
cruelly sat on the sidelines for all of
it the new timeline theory the one I had
been going with makes Bucky's old cap
reaction a bit odd because he should be
totally thrown off and confused by
everything he's seen but the same
timeline theory the wrong interpretation
actually could make Bucky's reaction
sensible it could suggest that Bucky at
some time after 2014 the events of
Captain America the Winter Soldier got
approached by old cap and then that
these two just stayed off the grid and
during the secret side friendship old
cap could have explained to Bucky his
eventual plan to show back up in 2023
moments after his younger self went back
in order to hand off the shield of Sam
the problem is I just do not like the
screenwriters same timeline theory it
contradicts their own time-travel logic
and it makes cap too much of a lazy
creeper who let 9/11 happen so I propose
to you a second explanation for how
Bucky knew what he knew let's assume the
new timeline theory and that cap lived
at his life in an alternate off-screen
history and that he found some
technological way to return to this
timeline maybe like meeting up with Hank
Pym to get his Pym particles some time
after 2015
and then dusting off that stark tech
risk
watching blasting his old bones back
down the time vortex pipeline in this
case caps arrival point could have been
any time kind of like back to the future
marty realizes he didn't have to return
precisely when his past self went back
he could give himself 10 more minutes
lead time but rather than arriving early
to warn his buddy about Libyan
terrorists in this case cap could have
arrived 10 minutes early just to creep
out his buddy and tell him what was
about to happen
therefore the cap that told Bucky what
was about to happen was not the young
cap suiting up it was a creepy old
future cap hiding behind a dream well I
guess it doesn't have to be creepy he
could have been sitting on that bench
for 10 minutes and just no one happened
to look over its that Bucky and then he
could have told him look when the time
is right you can direct their attention
over to me okay so I really couldn't
have gone back with you because again
only that older cap would know or care
about who inherits his shield younger
cap who goes back was not ready to hand
off that shield yet his main focus was
returning to a soul mate getting that
life Tony told him to get and he knew
that in the alternate 1940s life he
would have lived out there was still
some avenging and Hydra bashing to take
care of he'd made the shield and then
only after living out that life and
retiring would he know what to do next
either way caps movements will forever
be shrouded in mystery but one man knows
more than he let on his longtime buddy
Bucky Barnes what total conspiracy do
you think I should investigate next
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at
ETA vas fallen new rock stars in social
media at rock stars and subscribe to us
on youtube to join us as we investigate
every weird acting choice and under
thought plot point
[Music]